we're starting where you belong [ __ ]
where you belong if you people getting
rid of fog I'm all for them looks like
I'm a [ __ ] you know when I first
climbed this mountain above the fog what
da flying [ __ ] now here is a metaphor
worth taking in you've entered a place
of clarity understanding peace
I came here really
I'm impressed Kasumi is here before you
do though we're not answering any more
just who the hell are you really there's
only one shent with that kind of face
and a mind of his own right I only see
Nick
it can't be you the [ __ ] things huh
what are you trying to pull yes if
you're willing to give me a chance it
was either almost dying is this a joke
let me tell you what after we were
prototypes Nick the first sense capable
of independent thinking and judgment out
ahead Auken one of the Institute's
experiments had to do with how our
brains could process person average I
was allowed to develop mine based on
experience but with you they wanted to
try Trent it took several attempts
before the person out I couldn't let
them do it to you anymore you were my
brother Mick
if I were your way I'd remember that's
where you'd be wrong this happened over
a century ago there's I I've heard it I
think you and I need to talk about this
sure
we'll talk later Nick I don't need you
to believe me now about young Kasumi I
asked you before if you think she's
she's human but imagine what it means if
you are wrong if Kasumi is a sin none of
us take this transition likely that
someone stripped her very I want you to
understand that before you see her
uh-huh one more question if you'll
indulge me I tell me art
how would I even I'm afraid if you're
looking for some but instead you have to
look for this but ultimately
I'm a human being not a synth are you
sure
I was with my wife but no memories
before then that's usually a sign data
is easy isn't it funny how a memory can
feel like a whole different reality SS
people places I won't lie to you there
will always be other explanation but I
can promise you that you thank you I'm
glad to hear it and I'm sure you're
eager to talk
yeah you should know what
but that also means the techno sorry I'm
not going to judge the action is there
anything ever
who are you I came to this huh but after
my escape felt was secured I was left
with one day it finally is there
anything I should get going of course
perhaps there a long time yeah are you
feeling all right I'm fine you worry too
much sometimes I feel like you don't
worry enough you know we blew three more
relays this week I'm coming in you'll
stay right there and Sam a right yeah
cat semi uh yeah circuitry is completely
fried assuming nocona sorry I'm right in
the middle of something was having a
hardon your parents sent me the but they
did what look my mom and dad I mean
kusoo Neil is believe me I've thought
about that I thought if I just left it
would be I've been lying to you this
whole time
you haven't replaced I I really wish
that was true like oh but I can't leave
until I've got
if something's going I don't know how
you could wait what if i told you that
there's a secret yes
all right okay bread you saw all those
computers that dmoz hooked up to write
well faraday asked me to help do some
repairs on them and uh huh that's when i
see it the data models dima has been
making one was the fog taking over far
harbor what if dima is so open and
welcoming because he's actually we
should get to the bottom of this if dima
is putting on and out yeah yeah no I'll
help I know I've been more I keep seeing
Dima Faraday and chase head into the
laboratory at the other end of the hall
there's actually a storage space right
next I've also tried breaking into
Faraday's term
and this will be easier if I great good
luck from one case to a new one it's
never easy for us if I swear if someone
has the key to that story where's
Faraday's confirm it all is there
anything else on this level oh [ __ ] come
on come on sweet
I made stopping
ash at
you get on your ass or what
is it we need to accomplish this without
bloodshed far Harbor and the children of
Adam have a right to exist on this
island the same as us they're going to
kill each other Dima there's no stopping
it we need to pick a side now haven't we
already picked aside building the fog
condensers around far harbour wasn't
exactly a neutral act we couldn't stand
by and let the people of this island die
to the fog just like you couldn't just
leave the cult of Adam without a home
giving them the submarine base was a
mistake the nucleus as they're calling
it is basically one big fortified
position far harbour had cast them out
they have strange beliefs but they have
always accepted us for work okay and
confessor Martin was a friend well the
new confessor isn't hi confessor tactus
is an unstable megalomaniac and he's
gonna keep threatening us as long as
we're helping far guys can we talk about
the elephant in the room we keep dancing
around it my old memory banks in the
submarine base I can't believe you never
told me about those I have to wait until
they become a security risk I know how
it looks in hindsight but at the Texas
it was an act of trust I was honestly
more worried they'd accidentally tripped
the pre-war security and get hurt giving
the children my old home allowing them
to safeguard my old memories I thought
our people would be working together
just how secure the bank's how long do
we have and what's in them I've gone
over this before chase I don't know
what's in them that's how it works it's
as close to forgetting something as I
have
I've run some projections of worst-case
scenarios if we do nothing and the wrong
knowledge falls in the wrong hands so
send me over there I'll be in and out in
a day we can't risk it they know you're
from Acadia if you're caught or even
seen that it's war we should at least
prepare her to go in we're running out
of onions I say we tell her how to crack
into the memory banks you've been
working on this without me it came up in
a private moment chase but yes we've
been writing a program that will let you
access and download my memories it's not
going to be like a normal hack you'll be
breaking through a version of my own
mental network it'll consider you to be
an intruder I've loaded the program with
some instructions I've recorded that
will help guide you through it I'm
afraid it's difficult to explain without
seeing it for yourself I'm finishing up
some tweaks to the program right now
okay I'll leave a copy of it or you on
my desk when I'm done get the program
use it to break into the memory banks
got it hopefully you won't have to we'll
keep monitoring the situation I only
want you going in if we have no other
choice okay okay
all right it says God you must got his
fingers everywhere on this island and
what evers in his memories isn't
something we can wait for someone else
to find you see a lot of folks that
their worst in my line of work hard to
not let it get to you sometimes mmm [ __ ]
I had to go upstairs so
a [ __ ] i missed a [ __ ] stare so we're
here there's right here right yeah not a
good [ __ ] up here I'm gonna say I just
Tom I know what's up
is that
he has gone on hey dima yes what is it
I know you left some of your memories
behind you've been busy I was hoping you
were taking your time learning maybe
this is an opportunity for both of us
but you what are you planning before I
begin how much
I know all I then my plan is simple in
the old i'll give you the UH it's not
going to be I've loaded I can race team
if we're lucky one more thing our
ultimate goal must be if we find
anything suspicious and those memories
of yours will be oh it's just like
rotated me that's weird okay katsumi are
you ready to start a family turns out
demons earliest memories are in the
hands of the children of Adam he's
afraid of what they're gonna find so is
that what those desperate [ __ ] is he
still hiding something do you have a
wait I'm getting don't worry I have
money he lived up I got this program
really I wonder I'll bet that's it I'm
sorry
yeah kicks out for Harambee